so yeah i thought we could talk about the kidnap
robot problem today so kidnap robot problem is a
problem that is defined for mobile robots where
you take a robot from a known location and put
it in the space somewhere where the robot
doesn't know where it is and it tries to
relocalize itself to find where it is in that
space and basically a mobile robot tries to solve
a couple of problems which is the one one that
is maybe the underlying question is where am i
i don't know if there's any scope in explaining
what it is this is a toy mobile robot
and it has actuators motors here which would
drive these wheels and it has several sensors
such as sonar sensors here infrared sensors
here color sensor that looks in the ceiling
because this robot was trying to find this
way looking at some landmarks on the ceiling
and what this robot could try to do in its
life would be to navigate to a certain location
to move around to maybe clean up a space
and so on and the kidnapped robot problem
is when i take this robot from the known
location from the known map and put it
somewhere else and it will need to figure out
where it is in this known area um so we have
in several algorithms in robotics where the robot
could also try to create the map while trying
to localize itself um but the kidnapped robot
problem can be conceptualized within a known map
as well and this is the simplest way to probably
start explaining about what this with robotics
what we differ from ai is we really live
in a very dynamic and real world and
ai and robotics have been discussed in
conjunction with each other from 5th days on
because robotics has been an application
area of ai for quite a while even now
but the problems that robotics focuses on
are more difficult because they are more
real and the constraints are more real time
so for example if you utilize computer vision
for this robot for example if you had cameras um
you wouldn't train it or you would train it with
static images but you wouldn't
work with static images you would
work with a dynamic scene and the robot would
need to probably leverage that this leverage
is movement capabilities to get a better view
of the scene maybe dynamically change it and
do it in real time so the problems
of the robot is typically harder and
it's is buried in with a lot of uncertainty about
what it can do and what the world is about because
the robot starts with the representation of the
world let's say a map so in this area because this
is a two-dimensional robot you could create these
the scene with certain obstacles and it would
probably use its sensors to create an obstacle
map so it would say that here are probably some
obstacles and i'm saying probably because you
can't really trust anything on the robot these
sensors they may be broken they may if working
even working properly have uncertainty in readings
they have sensitivity especially with these kind
of cheap robots they have range they have limited
capabilities and the motors as well you think for
example i would actuate this robot this wheel what
wheels with the same velocity and let's say this
one wheel is actually not as large as the swamp
for example and you would have a small drift
and then that would actually change how your
how you're moving so the robot might think that it
is moving one meter forward but it might be maybe
drifting and these drifts these areas accumulate
over time which makes this localization problem a
very hard one because it needs to correct every
time so drift is one of the major problems because
when you think about programming a robot you could
maybe come up with the idea that i would just
actuate the motors i would make it draw a square
and you would expect it to draw a perfect square
oh this is a quite difficult task because
if i try to for example draw a square here
i would look at the paper and i would try to make
it look decent and even with my very good sensors
my actuation is not very robust and i couldn't
really draw a very solid square but when you
think of it if i close my eyes and if i try to
do the same task again i would do even worse
so this is my attempt with the closed eyes that's
pretty good actually that's pretty good actually
but anyways because this is not actually fully
open loop so there's these two concepts closed
loop and open loop in this one i was
actually correcting the motion through
looking at it so i'm having this measurement the
sensing to correct the motion and in here i shut
down one of my sensory modalities i didn't shut
everything because i still have proprioception
where i know where my hand is in space so i have a
rough idea that i'm drawing nicely so if you think
about maybe walking around with closed eyes in
a complex trajectory you would possibly get lost
and the robot is not different because there is
i say a lot of uncertainty in the internal system
of the robot but also within the world if it is
walking or it is driving on a sand scene then it
would drift more if it is really slippery it would
also drift and so on that's why these robots are
typically employed with these sensors and in
modern robotics we try to compensate for the
uncertainties of the sensing the actuation and the
environment by merging information by supporting
information so that you leverage the extra
information that you acquire from your sensors
from known things in the environment by to make
your movement better and to eventually obtain
localization which brings us to the kidnapped
robot problem if the robot is in a complete open
area with no landmarks and so on the localization
problem is uh very difficult and when you think of
it if you have this massive area which is empty um
like this area for example you like this room it
has quite a lot of landmarks um it can be anywhere
so if i place this robot for example in here
and if it only has this distance sensors
it would probably be wouldn't be able to
understand whether it is here here here all
of them are the same information for the robot
for the specific case because it only has these
frontal sensors if this robot has for example some
vision system if i did put it here then it would
see maybe certain things on the floor and then it
would know that it's probably not in this area
because you don't actually expect any of these
landmarks in that area but it wouldn't be sure
because you can't trust the sensor there is still
a possibility that you're seeing a black frame but
maybe your sensor is wrong so what you're seeing
is incorrect and we incorporate that kind of
information when we try to self-localize the robot
do you move the robot several times there how does
it you know how does it cope with that um yeah
well it would have to move around and look so
it's a single sensory measurement it would have
for example we actually have a nice example here
if i put my robot here or here or here actually
the scene looks very very similar so if the robot
is actually here it would probably it would say
that i might be here i might be here or i might be
here and we do represent this true probabilities
in modern robotics so this idea of probabilistic
robotics has been the dominant approach to program
robots at the moment and what we do is we use
mathematical formulations the solid statistical
formulations to refine the uncertainty so that
we have a better belief about our decisions and
in the specific case the location of the robot
so what would this robot do in this situation is
this is actually quite a textbook example
so we have our robot here which is
maybe moving in this direction and
there are three doors in front of it and
let's put it a little bit far away for adding more
interest and what the robot does is it actually
continuously updates this belief over the state
of all positions and in the beginning you may
think that robots have an equal probability of all
locations so we start with a uniform distribution
saying that within this positional space it can be
equally anywhere and then it takes a measurement
let's say this is the first step and with
the measurement it would then have data
enough to update this belief then you would
know that it's so a door in front of it
so the belief would be updated to
say that i'm probably here here
or here add it onto this probability distribution
function through the use of three gaussians and
giving me this three peaks in the distribution
showing probably where i am and i'm not killing
these probabilities of being for example here
because as i say your sensor could be wrong
but this is not good enough because i still
don't know where i am and i still have a lot
of possibilities so i have to refine this and in
order to define this i would make the robot move
and the movement actually brings in a lot of
more information this is one of the powers
of the robots that they can actually change
their location they can start gathering more
information so by moving you actually
introduce uncertainty into the motion
into the probability distribution belief because
your motors your actuators they can be wrong as
well and that information would be used to again
collect more information through measurements
and in here after the moment what we do is we
shift our beliefs so this is the second step
and this is again the belief and i knew that i
was here and i will be moving maybe up till this
point my probable locations will be moving one
meter forward as well however these probabilities
are a little bit wider than this ones because i
have brought in some more uncertainty through the
movements and after this step i'm still in the
similar position where i don't know where i am
and what i would do is i would take
another measurement and this is once again
used to update my belief and what i saw here
is luckily i came in front of another door
so i would be once again here because everything
could have been wrong up till this point
but probably i'm not here because i have seen
actually two doors and i trust my sensory
information so that probably i would have a better
belief here i could have been still here because
there was some probability over there and then
i could have been here as well so i'm probably
in front of the door even with two steps in the
story problem but iterating these over and over
sensing and updating the belief and then
moving and updating i would get a much better
posterior belief about where i am and presumably
adding other sensors in and more movement
and different dimensions is all possible yes you
can add multiple sensors especially and they do
often help as long as you confuse the
information nicely and typically in
robotics applications we do make use of many
sensors even in this robot we have quite many
for example in outdoor robotics you can use gps
to correct some of the motions that information
is not once again correct but if you're on a road
for example you have that constraint if you move
you would have that constraint and that would be
used to perfect your positioning although we all
know that for example when we are tracing our card
information is not always the perfect one but it's
a probabilistically good one if the space looks
very much alike then you're kind of in trouble
because this algorithm which uses a base filter
actually uses the similarities in space so the
robot always tries to find something that can be
distinguishable that looks like it works well for
a scene that the robot has already seen i've seen
that it's seen an area that it already knows okay
what happens if you put it somewhere it's
not seen before well in that case we it would
need to create the map as well and that is done
through this slam algorithm typically which is
simultaneous localization and mapping so it
would gather the information to create the
map as well as to localize itself so it would
wander around the environment and would try to
eventually find a space a location that can close
the loop and say that oh i've been here before
so this is how the map should be so at every
step it's actually fixes the map a little bit
cool slime wouldn't sound like another video yeah
probably char char is a bit like a hash function
in the sense that it takes a block of data and it
mixes it up and it uses that for its key stream
so we have a block and we'll talk about what
goes in there in a moment jacobson one of
the great creators of the internet he's one of
the men who made the internet work and helped
AUTOCAPS Manual Publish